hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the super bit chess classic
this time from round five it's fabiano
carwana versus shakhtar mahmoud and i
don't want to spoil anything but this
may very well be at the only a decisive
game of the round uh or it may not uh we
will have to
check it out and see
uh and it's incredibly interesting as uh
uh mamijarov plays the petra of defense
and we all know that uh fabi prepared
the petrov defense for his 2018 world
championship championship match against
magnus carlsen and he knows the
intricacies of the opening in and out so
uh let's uh well let's uh let's just
enjoy what happened here so fabi has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 like
we said e5 knight to f3 and mamadyarov
goes for the petrov with knight to f6 we
have knight captures on e5 going for the
classical variation knight
sorry d6 challenging the knight knight
to f3 and the knight captures on e4 and
now fabi goes for d4 this is the
classical attack against the petrov and
it is the i believe the most played line
uh against the petrov we have d5 bishop
to d3 bishop to e7 and here we have
castles bishop to f5 now and rook to e1
we have castles and now knight beat to
d2 putting more pressure uh to the
knight on e4 so just knight back to d6
offering a trade of light square bishops
knights to f1 and here mommy of trades
with captures captures and now c6
strengthening the d5 pawn the ship to f4
and now knight to a6 uh we have h4 by
fabi uh and knight to c7 now we have
knight to g5 already threatening
checkmate and mamiyarov defends with the
g6 uh and now
uh the position has been reached before
for example uh wesley so had it against
the youngshish of duda where uh knight
to e3 was an attempt in that game that
game ended in a draw
but here we have knight to h2 uh
preparing uh to remaneuver the knight
and it's still not a new move uh there
is a game where f6 was played last year
in the feeder grand swiss between
anti-breaking and maxim matlakov um the
the that game ended by berkich winning
uh so f6 even though it's uh amongst the
engine recommendations it's not the
absolute first one my majero plays queen
to the queen to d7 and this is the
absolute top choice recommended by the
engine so now as of move 15 we have a
completely new game how does fabi
continue this he starts with h5 and of
course it makes sense black can never
capture as queen captures on h7 would be
checkmate so he eliminates one of the
attackers bishop captures on g5 bishop
captures and now rook f28 and now
already you can uh sense something that
we often discuss when when it happens uh
no longer has a dark square bishop he
has his pawns on light squares in front
of the king which means he has a lot of
dark square weaknesses
around his king and it's not going to be
easy to cover them so uh
fabi has the dark square bishop he has
the queen and it could be possible to
create some sort of a checkmating attack
so h captures on g6h captures and bishop
to f6 now now already you can see that
maybe queen d2 queen h6 this will be
checkmate uh mama yara needs to defend
this uh somehow but first uh there's
rook captures on e1 with check real
captures and rook to e8 so for the
moment you don't have to worry about
getting checkmated rook to f1 fabia
avoiding the trade and now
uh mamiya uh has to continue with
something like queen to five or for a
queen trade or maybe even queen to e6
just doubling up on the e file but he
plays a move uh that is weird uh knight
the a6 uh
mamira already played uh from ba knight
to a6 then he put it the c7 and now he
brings it back to a6 and um it's hard
hard to say what the knight is doing on
a6
but one thing it doesn't do is help
black in any way because here fabi has a
move
that
makes black's position uh almost
unplayable uh so feel free to pause this
video and try to find this incredible
move by fabi
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
maneuvering idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
bishop to e5 that's the good stuff uh
now uh not only do we still uh have all
of the threats here that
are created if we somehow do get a
mating attack but what we actually do
here uh we freed up the f6 square for
the for the white knight now knight to
g4 knight to f6 looked at this monster
for king and g8 rook and eight queen and
d7
uh black just falls apart so mamadou
really needs to
do something about this and uh it's not
easy he plays queen to e6 so now one
thing you want to do is get your pieces
off of these squares uh and now fabi
plays f4 and this is where fabi kind of
drops the ball uh because queen the uh
instead of f4 queen the g3 sort of wins
the game on the spot for him although
it's not not at all clear how uh the
point is you are still threatening queen
to h4 and the point uh after let's say
94 attacks the queen queen h4 black will
have to play f6 otherwise you're just
going to get checkmated we're going to
play f3 and now after pawn captures
bishop quang captures knight
it's uh it's uh again an unplayable
position if the knight comes to g4 then
the game is over you have access to f6
you have access to h6 so blank has to
play this we're going to play rogue
captures king captures now queen h8
check king the e7 and queen g7 check and
that's uh all there is uh for this game
now if the queen blocks we're gonna
start capturing an e5 with check if the
king moves we start capturing on b7 with
tempo the knight will get attacked and
this will be completely uh uh losing for
black so unfortunately for fabi he
doesn't uh find this he plays f4 he
wants to uh
push f5 and must open the position
knight to b8 this is how mamiyarov will
bring the knight back into the game and
now comes queen to a3 f5 right away is
uh still uh very much playable for
example f5 knight captures now queen h3
going after checkmate and uh there's not
all that much you can do if knight g7
just queen h6 so we have to play f6 now
and again g4 the knight uh helps us
create something here for example if
captures g captures g captures king h1
you get this position where white is
better but
how much better it's uh well uh fabi
definitely decides that it is not enough
so he plays queen to a3 uh with a double
attack on the knight here mamadar moves
at 94 and only now that the knight no
longer controls f5 uh fabi pushes f5
g captures on f5 now comes queen to h3
so ifavi was successful in opening up
the king a little bit now he's
threatening checkmate queen to h8 so f6
has to be played and now we have rook
captures on f5 and it's a very very
tricky idea but of course the bishop
cannot be captured if you capture the
bishop then queen g4 check and that's it
the king has no good squares once you
move the king rook h5 and that's it
black will have to give up the queen but
you don't even have to rush it you can
play knight f3 and at will you can
capture here and your position will be
completely winning
so after knight after rook captures on
f5 knight the d7 uh mamidarov
slowly but surely getting this knight
into the game uh bishop to f4 now uh
now the bishop is no longer attacked and
white's position is just better king the
f8 momidaro will now try to hide his
king all the way on the queen side with
queen a3 check not allowing this uh and
now king back to g7 you could also try
blocking with queen e7 probably queen to
b3 then going after b7 so just uh uh
you know putting the pressure button
it's not very serious king g7 we have
rook to h5 now and a6 as the a7 pawn was
a target queen to b3 going after b7 now
pawn to b6 we have queen to f3 now comes
rook to h8 offering a trade of rooks and
here fabi trades we have captures
captures and queen to h5 with check king
g8 queen g6 check and now king to f8 we
have knights to g4 finally the knight
comes to g4 uh in the now king to e7
still mamiyarov wants to try and hide
his king here on b7 and fabi will of
course try to prevent this knight h6 we
have king to d8 knights the f7 check we
have king to e7 if you go king c8 then
you get checkmated it's a very important
not to do this knight to d8 check for
the king and the queen but also it's
just checkmate very very quickly so king
the east uh so a king the e7 has to be
played knight the h6 we have king d8
knight to
knight to f5 now sorry uh and now comes
king the c8 so mommy
escapes successfully with the king uh
but queen the g for now uh threatening a
very nasty discovery here to pick up the
black queen so king back to d8 now comes
queen to h3 queen to e8 not allowing
queen to h8 to check now comes queen to
h7 uh we have knights the g5 attacking
the queen here and we have a trade
captures captures and queen to g7 so fab
is still putting pressure on
on mohammed yav the material is
completely equal but of course fabi's
position is much more active queen the
e1 would check king h2 and now uh
luckily the knight is guarding the h4
square otherwise it would just be a
perpetual queen to d2 and now queen to
e7 with check king c7 we have queen d6
check king to d8 and now knight to e7
going after the c6 pawn there's no good
way to prevent this and um
well queen to f2 is the safest try once
you play queen to f2 uh then well
you are threatening this perpetual and
white will have a very hard time uh not
uh
not allowing black to to do this but
after knight a queen captures on c2
grabbing a pawn now uh fabi definitely
has more than a draw knight captures on
c6 with check king the c8 now comes 97
check king to d8 knight to c6 check
fabio repeats the position a few times
uh king to c8 and not knights to e7 with
check we have king to d8 and finally
knight captures on d5 grabbing bag of
the pawn queen to h7 check king to g1 we
have queen to b1 check king h2 and queen
to h7 with king g1 queen b1 check if now
fabio repeats then it's a draw by
threefold repetition so king f2 queen c2
check now comes king to e3 we have queen
to c1 with check king d3 and now uh we
have king the c8 but
regardless of what you do you will not
be able to continue checking the king
for example queen c1 uh we we can move
wherever we want we can go to e4 queen
e2 check we can go knight to e3 now
and uh it's just not going to be
possible or even better uh after this uh
queen to c2 we're gonna go to e3 uh e4
uh
allows black a bit a bit too much here
queen to e1 king to d3 and now after
queen to d3 we can play something like
king to c3 so that would be that would
be better queen to c1 king to be three
and we successfully hide on the queen
side queen to d1 check and now kink the
a3 queen to d3 check and finally b3 this
is how we uh stop uh stop all the checks
so mandarin doesn't go for this instead
he plays a king the c8 now comes queen
to e6 with queen to f1 with chuck king
to c3 queen to c1 check king b3 queen d1
check king a3 and again we get this uh
position where uh uh fabi just blocks
with b3 we have
queen to b5 and now just king to b2 and
he was in this position on move 66 that
shakhtar and mommy are resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh you don't have a check here e2 square
is covered by the queen and whatever you
try let's say you play a5
uh where we just have to
get the black queen to stop defending
the knight here and it's game over we
succeeded this by playing a4 and now the
queen can no longer keep defending the
knight once the queen moves uh we play
queen eight check and that's it the c7
square is covered by the knight you have
to move this force with czech king to b8
or whatever queen to c7 checking eight
knight captures on b6 uh and that's uh
that's it we we force black to give up
the queen and now of course uh
we will checkmate the black king uh
luckily for us black has a g pawn if
black did not have a jeep on this um uh
would of course be stalemate the black
king has nowhere to go uh but luckily uh
he does so uh we don't have to worry
about such things but yeah after king to
b2 mamadou resigned and a wonderful
wonderful
victory for fabiana corona now i'm sure
this was some
elaborate uh uh preparation by mohammed
yarov but this repeated knight the a6
idea
and i mean knight the a6 the c7 the a6
the b8 really
really weird stuff that's four moves
uh that allowed fabi to just uh seize
the initiative with bishop to e5
grabbing hold of this key f6 square and
that's basically the the story of this
game fabi did not play the absolute
perfect uh
lines and the mamador did have some uh
some opportunities to get back into the
game but still here here this is just
another example of even though the
engine might suggest that the strongest
move would be to give up a black's dark
square bishop but here you can just see
how how inconvenient it is for for a
human to play this because it's just a
very unnatural to create weaknesses
around your king and give up your your
dragon basically so that's not uh
very very hard to play i mean uh if you
like this you can play it but i i would
not play this
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it also here are the standings
if you missed the previous video so the
leader of the tournament is wesley saw
with a current score of three and a half
points followed by um three people uh
with three points level in oregon maxine
bashar lagraven and daniel diack uh fabi
and yanni palmitia with two and a half
with two points ali reza fierro jericho
rapport dominguez and in the last place
for the moment with one and a half point
shakhri mamidarov who is not having a
great tournament but still four rounds
left in the tournament anything can
still happen uh so yeah i once again i
really hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
rodolf nrc uh lb and i would like to
thank claudio bovelli and alessandro
bossie yogeshpati donating because it is
the strongest move person uh and tarek
adala for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
magnificent event uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day